eigentlich nicht hallo mein name ist
zusätzlich will kommen heute zu einem
neuen video dass meine augen bisschen
glasig angeschwollen sind meinen mund
trocken
ich bin dort in der sonne eingeschlafen
32 grad ihr seht schon sicher
eingeblendete es geht heute um einen
whatsapp renk ja das haben schon andere
und videos von denen sind in der
beschreibung verlinkt danke für die idee
finde ich super coole wollte ich
unbedingt gern mal selbst ausprobieren
erkläre ich mal ganz kurz worum es dabei
überhaupt diesen trails und man sich
einfach ein lied aus nimmt sich aus dem
lied einfach so 45 verschiedene lions
und schreibt die einem freude deiner
freunde bei orts- und schaut einfach wie
er sehen wir sie darauf reagiert und ich
habe das als erstes bei max gemacht das
sieht was ich mir für max raabe ist wer
anders von stents bringt hier ein
kleiner ausschnitt schlanke produktion
für den über hausen lies langen
ausschnitt
ich zeige euch mal einfach die ärzte
sache die ich mag es geschrieben aber
nutzen mit zehntausenden wenn ich nicht
zufrieden bin und meinen eine jazzig
feiern kann dick kazak sven sagt in
seinem liter halt so was in die richtung
wie ja ich habe schon 10.000 alben
gemacht aber was bringt es mir wenn ich
das selbst nicht feiern kann ich hab das
dann bitte noch nicht formuliert also
was bringen die hunderttausende von
abonnenten mehr oder weniger aber wenn
ich will mal konnte nicht identifizieren
kann man seine antwort war heute 6000
ach so gestern
ich glaube er bezieht sich da irgendwie
auch meinen abonnentenzuwachs aber darum
ging es nicht mal sein dass sie es
tatsächlich zwei stunden lang
durchgehalten
es tut mir leid dass ich euch mir so
zeigen muss aber ich bin halt einfach in
der sonne eingeschlagen ging es halt
weiter mit
ich bin schon lange hier habt ihr
problem damit wollte ich einfach sagen
ich mache mich nicht so lange ich habe
schon sehr viele ausprobiert seine
reaktion darauf war
danke für diese aussagen der aussage
gemacht hab ich eigentlich wollte
vernunft oder freunde gefunden das war
dann schon sehr ob wir es muss ich
zugeben also dass jemand einfach so
schreibt aus nix ich frag mich ob das
alles richtig ist was ich mache habe ich
freunde gewonnen oder freunde verloren
und dann hat es maximal auch getrotzt
break mit songtexten gar nicht geklappt
ich habe mich davon aber wirklich nicht
beirren lassen und habe weiter mein ding
durchgezogen 10 sei es für mich alles
was zählt das ist doch super
doch ich bereue was ich getan hat noch
mehr supi
das habe ich ihm dann geschickt max
leider nicht ganz so gut geklappt das
nicht lange durch allerdings habe ich
nach meiner anderen freunden das ist der
stoff um schnaps angewandte tieren ganz
kurzer ausschnitt ich hab's doch
produktion er sei nicht die besten
ich werde nicht gewusst wir wollen das
verdient das war die erste sache die ihr
geschickt hatte als ich werde nicht
lügen wir wollen was verdienen weil das
eine freundin von mir die ist gerade auf
die bizarren partyurlaub und ich dachte
okay die ist vielleicht die kranken
sonst und ich kann ich jetzt ganz gut
für ihre antwort war was h
die hatte überhaupt kein plan worum es
gehen ich habe daran gedacht die deckt
jetzt so ja überhaupt eine geschäftsidee
so dass wir zusammen irgendwie geld
verdienen könne so deswegen abgesagt und
seele gespielt wie ich mache das hier
ihre reaktionen darauf waren wir haben
luca kassiert ja und lukas hier kein
platz und mutig sagt dass ich sage ich
habe mit dieser aussage keine plattform
und ich sag was ich sage extra pause
vielleicht hinter geplant hinter geplant
gut kriegen euch kunst funktion
produktion billiger ich habe diese
verschiedene sachen übrigens mit dem
high five lachen und dem musikhaus von
ins copa also grüßen rau san diego ihre
antwort auf mich nehme kein blatt vor
bundes sage was ich sage hat mich aus
der spur geschliffen ihre antwort war
angeblich hunger hunger als klassiker
antworte einfach das so hunger hast
damit aus dem gleichen lied die zange
genommen wenn es mir schlecht geht es
niemand am start wenn es mir schlecht
geht ich niemals zum start um ihr halt
so zu zeigen dass mich das echt nicht
ernst mir ist echt ein wichtiges thema
ihre reaktion darauf war ist nicht
witzig für mich ging es da echt uns ganz
wichtig ist nämlich ich habe schnupfen
und schnaps und schnell das war mir sehr
wichtig in dem moment an da
sie hat jetzt begriffen wie weit es geht
um dieses lied und fasst sie land
schreibt einfach so korrekt komme sie
hatte sich geweigert das ganze dann auf
jeden fall aufgelöst und nach der name
geschrieben wo man halt ich wollte dich
mit songtexten franken für ein
youtube-video haben voll nach hinten los
gegangen darfst du machst dir dann
sorgen um mich oder so haha und sie
danach nur so die opfer hahn ein mann du
bist ja schlecht ich kann sich nicht
bevor sich irgend jemand beschweren
sollte und ja ich weiß das alles auch
noch spaß aber ich sage das hat nun
immer weil nicht dass irgendwelche
ältere person sehen und denken erfahren
hat was gegen die ich habe allen
personen die ich hier veranstalten
nachher gesagt ja das war von youtube
video die für alle damit einverstanden
dass ich's hochladen das ist das machte
und haben es cool gefunden
so let's move on dann habe ich mal der
kontaktliste ein kumpel von mir aus
berlin gefunden hat nämlich alex und
dann habe ich das lied gewählt
eigentlich von veh in ganz kurzer
ausschnitt alter produktion das kann so
nicht weitergehen
und er ist auf jeden fall richtig ernst
genommen hat dann direkt geantwortet was
h hat sie doch berliner machen wir einst
kassel tätig dann gehen wir eine
korrekte antwort alexander bock drauf
haben weiterhin gesagt so eigentlich
will ich ja gern aber ich bin mal kurz
ein mit dem song und dann natürlich
wieder typische alex reaktion ich fliege
am 31 nach boston kommt mit und ja das
reisen
er hatte überhaupt keinen plan
eigentlich nicht
zwei sachen dazu eben ich weiß dass die
frau gesagt hat als ich jetzt gerade bin
und ich gesehen habe hat sich jetzt
gewesen bin aber hat es in dem moment
irgendwie halt falsch verstanden die
zweite sache da hat sich weiters hat
gerade nicht mit dieser reise hier zu
tun aber ich dachte das wäre vielleicht
ganz jungen wollen mal gucken was
erscheint und er hat geschrieben hast
was getrunken
aber wir machen weiter und das finde ich
habe ich richtig gut gemacht weil er
geschrieben hast du was getrunken habe
ich so voll normaal geantwortet ist noch
ganz ohne fahrer sich suche nach dem
sinn muss ich mir echt man selbst und
die schulter klopfende produktion
man kennt ok nächste woche freitag
suchen wir nach dem sinn hat er dann
halt geantwortet weil wir haben freitag
feiern sind zusammen und vielleicht
seien von ihr zu klug hat die sache die
wir als nächstes geschrieben hast du
vielleicht ein bisschen zu feiern
natürlich mehr ist aber ich fand's
einfach witzig das sagte ich mir will
das nicht
und danach habe ich halt aufgelöst und
hat gesagt ja er wusste schon so dachte
dass man wenn die hatte das bei mir
umgegangen hat gesagt er ist nicht mein
handy oder wusste ja ich habe er hat
irgendwie auch rausgefunden auf jeden
fall
dann habe ich mal wieder einen guten
alten kumpel von mir namens mal
geschrieben domo lücke domain leberwurst
logis und ihm habe ich dann doerigs aus
dem lied i kenn di von my handy von dem
blech reiz brass quintett featuring
special guest geschickt jemand kleiner
ausschnitt ist es euer ernst hatte ihnen
eine ahnung dass die leute vielleicht
doch mal sehen wo wärst was ich ihnen
daraus geschrieben hatte waren auf jeden
fall ist gibt armee das macht mich ganz
verrückt werden alle zusammen im urlaub
oft so mädels gespräch und dachte ich
okay wenn ich baue jetzt schreibe ist es
echte komplett normale aussage so
manchen alten kumpel an so heißt dass er
mir das mal nicht erst darauf auch echt
gut eingegangen erstes hey was seit wann
daraufhin hab ich dann halt gesagt du
freundschaft und dann kam von moos und
die reaktion
war stimmig der hat also viel vertrauen
in mich dass ich mir solche sachen dann
vertraut dann habe ich gedacht okay ich
kriege ich das jetzt irgendwie hin dass
er nicht denkt dass ich ihm verarsche
und habe dann halt einmal die lyrics
genommen noch dazu geschrieben was soll
ich tun
einfach dass ich in so ein bisschen
länger das strippe habe sag ich mal
und da muss ich wirklich sagen haben
nach aussage von moritz wo ich mir
gedacht haben ok damit du dich nicht
gerechnet dass er mit so einem weisheits
gefüllten tipp gibt ihn mit zügigen pick
ok danke danke für dein tipp aber ich
wäre nicht klug wenn ich dann schon
aufgegeben hätte sondern ich habe dann
weiterhin gesagt jetzt ist die lage im
lokal erzählen und mein herz schlug
schneller als normal
ich weiß dass der typ gesungen hat und
mein herz schlug schneller als normal
und ich habe geschrieben hat herz
braucht viel schneller als normal aber
ich habe mich nicht sagt mein herz
schlägt viel schneller als normal ist in
dem moment allerdings noch eigentlich
scheißegal weil man danach geschrieben
hat alter weg dich du was mich aber ich
habe nicht aufgegeben
profit ist genau so stehen diese
original und dann ab moritz wieder
gezeigt warum ich ihn und seine band
über länder nach hat er mir das
geschickt ein bild von sich
danke moritz das was ihr vom wieder
meine damen und herren es euch gefallen
hat lassen auf jeden fall leichter wenn
ich das ganze noch mal machen soll
vielleicht mit partnerin wieder ein paar
kollegen ich meine daraus kann man
riesig lange serie schreibt man in die
kommentare
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran
eigentlich interessiert halt immer wenn
ich die videos mal kürzer mal länger wie
lange die leute wirklich dran sind und
das sagen wer sind die crew
wir sind von euch diese meine broß sind
und so dank an alle die mitgemacht haben
also an marco carola als hobby und alex
ihr seid super cool wenn wir hier oben
drückt könnt ihr meinen kanal abonnieren
und hier findet ihr ein weiteres video
ruhig auf musicals reagiert haben
schenkt das auf jeden fall auch marca
kommentiert frank derzeit das war ich
übrigens als neue end hat jetzt
neuerdings dass ich dass wir diesen
youtube elementen hier mache dass es
besser finde ich als wenn ich am ende
machen bild habe mit verschiedenen
videos oder sondern trotz persönlicher